welcome to Oktoberfest I am here at the
world's biggest beer festival millions
of people from around the world come to
Munich Oktoberfest and now I have come
to will I managed to meet people from 20
different countries in just one hour my
colleagues don't believe it but I don't
agree
Tom's running so I better get a move-on
just 59 minutes left I've got to hurry
hello wave New Zealand great I'm looking
for many different nations here in the
Oktoberfest what do you like most about
Oktoberfest everything
beer more beer better where are you from
I'm from Belarus hello Sorry Sorry
where are you from Maria Bruna Italian
French how do you say post in Belgium
and after all the BIA sooner or later
the nature courts and so did the cash
machines in recent years people from 70
different countries got money on the
Oktoberfest so let's see us online today
well it's half time already I've got a -
just 30 minutes left and I've only met
people from six countries where are you
guys from
sorry hi where are you from I'm from the
United States darn I had the u.s.
already and what do you think about the
German oompah music I love it I just
keep dancing in my seat and then
sometimes maybe on your seat 12
countries to go and how do you say posts
in your country what do you mean
how do you say it in China yeah can't be
can't be passe what good what is the
post we call it lehayim just 12 minutes
left and I still need six more Nations
it's gonna be close Philippines India
okay sorry sorry sorry where are you
from from Egypt I'm sorry sorry where
are you from from Nigeria and what do
you like most about the Oktoberfest it
is it is fantastic it cannot be
described if Germans are putting the
beer glasses together we say post
whoo-hoo laughs and you're putting your
glasses together you say whoo
I know where you're from Disneyland that
doesn't really count
I still need one one Asian just five
minutes left another attraction for
fairness at the Oktoberfest its own post
office just the place to send them
greetings to the folks back home Oh
exactly we are from Poland I'm sending
some greetings back home to say hello we
drink too much and maybe we come back
Taiwan and you're just here for the
Oktoberfest but I have the last laugh
and here ever inviting other people from
21 different nations in just 60 minutes
greetings from the Oktoberfest